well it is mid-winter and year three of
the pandemic feelings of exhaustion and
anxiety have been real for so many of us
as the months drag on but for some they
may have noticed there's a different
type of fatigue we're experiencing now a
phenomenon psychologists are calling
resilience fatigue for more insight on
this we're joined by dr vale wright a
clinical psychologist and researcher at
the american psychological association
thanks for speaking with us today dr
wright
thanks for having me all right so since
the start of the pandemic you know
there's been this consistent underlying
tiredness but it appears to have evolved
over time what exactly is resilience
fatigue
resilience fatigue is this feeling of
exhaustion that comes from the efforts
of having to cope and manage prolonged
stress over a long period of time in
this case over two years many people are
doing their best to be resilient but
with no end in sight i think people are
just kind of over it all right and the
finish line keeps moving i think we're
told okay just a couple months and if we
get to this point we'll be okay but that
keeps getting pushed back so i'm sure
that's part of it what are some of the
the common stressors of resilience
fatigue to be aware
of um so some of the things to be
thinking about is the ways in which our
stress impacts both us physically and
emotionally so physically we would
expect things like muscle tension
teeth grading
headaches stomach aches emotionally we
become angry and frustrated maybe even
hopeless and at the worst it's a loss of
empathy empathy for others empathy for
those around us and that empathy is
really critical especially right now and
so making sure that we're building
ourselves back up is incredibly
important all right and dr ray what else
can people do differently sort of this
time around this wave of fatigue to
address pandemic resilience fatigue but
in a healthy way
so there's always individual factors
that we need to keep in mind like making
sure we're eating healthy getting enough
sleep but we also need to look at our
environments around us can we talk to
our employer and make some changes to
really support our mental health can we
look at how things are happening within
our family and ensure that we're asking
for the support that we need that people
are all sharing the types of tasks that
need to occur on a daily basis so it's
about individual factors and our
environment all right now what's been
very interesting i think to see over the
course of the pandemic is that
people's fatigue is manifesting in very
different ways you know some are out in
big crowds surrounded by strangers
protesting the public health
restrictions while others are still
holed up at home you know everyone is
frustrated obviously by the pandemic but
there seems to be this divide in society
right now about how to respond to it
it's almost as if you're either on one
side
or the other so what are some of the
reasons for these two very different
reactions to the
pandemic probably a variety of reasons
certainly one is the polarization that
we're seeing across the country both
within our communities but even within
our families of how we're taking a
different approach to maybe managing our
own individual decision making during
the pandemic but i think what we're also
seeing now is a focus away from just
what individuals need to do to stop the
pandemic to looking at the ways in which
our systems have actually failed us and
i think that's where you're seeing so
much of this anger and frustration
coming out when we see things like
supply chain or the mental health crisis
systems that we've come to rely on not
being able to meet the demand of our
current situation all right and any
advice or tools that you would say to a
patient of yours or someone who comes to
you for help to just try and get through
sort of this last mile that we're you
know seeing the end in sight and also
maybe to even be able to bridge a gap
between someone who has a different view
from ourselves about the pandemic
now there's a few things one is to
remember to focus on what's in your
control because things are so uncertain
continue to be and that can make us feel
a loss of control so focusing on that is
important reminding ourselves that it
won't always be like this the only
constant in the world is change and so
the pandemic will likely come to an end
just as it has
for human history as long as we've been
and then the last thing would be to
really put our judgment out the door to
stop judging ourselves to stop judging
others for the ways in which people may
be handling things differently than you
are it's not the way that we're going to
get to the end of pandemic by judging
each other we really have to come
together as a community all right thank
you so much for your time and advice
today we appreciate it that's clinical
psychologist dr vale wright